you'll be funny if hobbits actually have
like huge dicks
like really huge thick like they're
small people
the size of a normal person yeah
enormous
dick is when when vivid releases the
hobbit desolation of schlong yeah
then you will get to see this kind of
[ __ ] cool
hello i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry
and i'm rachel welcome to reasons to say
where we give you reasons
to see and not to see the hobbit
desolation of smog so let's hang out
reason to see number one directing in
cinematography
all right people see we saw the hobbit
desolation of smog smack whatever the
hell
smog smog smith schmidt
what i liked about it a lot i thought
that directing and cinematography really
improved off the first one
definitely had a much darker tone the
moments were hit better
i thought that the emotional impact was
actually there i felt like in the first
half of peter jackson was getting his
feet wet again and in this one i felt
like it was more solidified and more
thought out because
it like jumps around a bunch of
different characters and so many times
i'd be like oh yeah that guy's in this
movie but i found each story to be very
interesting i was always
very much engrossed yeah uh i'm kind of
with you i mean i was sort of
intermittent on this movie there were
times when i was like oh this is way
cool and
i'm really digging this more you know
than the first one and then there are
times where i was like oh
you're losing me again well you're a
[ __ ] for feeling that i am i am a [ __ ]
i probably have an opinion on this topic
if i cared like at all
about the camera there's a there's some
cool tone you know there's some some
cool creepy visuals
i need i need more than just you know it
being a dark
thing and like oh look at how smooth
this is and look at how
dark this scene is you know well i
thought it was like really intense and
stuff at a lot of the time so
that's why i was more captivated by it i
mean that in and of itself
you know didn't captivate me didn't cat
it didn't give
back to kept activate me well you're an
[ __ ]
reason to see number two small
smearing he was one of my favorite
things about this movie yeah
he comes in so late into the film he's
like in the whole finale
awesome to watch like he's monologuing
the whole time
it's like that rare thing where a
dragon's talking and you're like i'm
really into everything this dragon's
saying right now hey matt
he doesn't even have to be on screen
when benedict cumberbatch is talking
you're like i'm listening to you man
and the effects on him were great it
didn't pull me out of the film going oh
that looks fake like i was i was pulled
into it enough to be like it was kind of
a scary [ __ ] dragon right now
i mean initially i wasn't really crazy
about the lines he was saying you know
there was a lot
of like where are you you know come on
you know it just seemed like
you know the writing for what he was
saying wasn't particularly uh
he's a dragon exactly you know he hasn't
talked to anybody in a long time yeah he
sleeps in a pile of gold
i think his his people's skills are
probably not he's the richest dragon
you'll ever meet
what does he spend the money on why does
he need the gold was this explained
because
dragon hose man reason to see number
three
visual effects for me carrying over from
the first one to
to this one i'm a little more used to
what's going on visually but i feel like
everything that was good and everything
that wasn't so good
is pretty steady really i felt like
pulled back into middle earth not just
the visual effects also with the
directing as well
i wasn't there watching it the whole
time going yay lord of the rings
one of the rings like i felt like it was
his own separate entity i mean they're
definitely
some really standout moments like i said
i mean it's only distracting to me when
it's
like the goblin army guys and it's all
cg and you're like oh it looks really
huge
you guys just have nothing good to say
about it i thought the spider scene was
wrapped the spider scene was
bomb dude and that's when i got hooked
reason to see number four
legolas i thought he was like [ __ ]
badass in this one and they did expand
upon his character more he felt more
important in this one than kind of in
the lord of the rings trilogy he's just
that cool guy with a bow and arrow they
gave him much more badass things to do
they didn't like expand vastly on his
character but they expanded enough to
make him more interesting to me
sure he did look like him yeah badass
with his arrows with his arrows
as like in 3d just now is good wait this
is not how you fire her up
i wasn't terribly invested in legolas
endeavors i felt like oh man i always
just thought he was so
cool so much of it i would be like oh
sick
reason to see number five toriel
evangeline lilly she's beautiful and
it's cool seeing a female character that
can kick some [ __ ] ass it's cool
seeing those two together like working
together and just
doing archery to people who are like a
foot away from them
honestly like i really like the two of
them and anything i
i feel like it almost could have been
more not action scenes with those two
characters involved in them having them
around was like i want to know more
about why you're here and what's going
on with you elves because this has
clearly become
more than a hobbit's journey and the
journey of the dwarves it's become a
middle-earth issue
reason to see number six
someone's my boy i like to enjoy
watching him more than frodo for sure i
think he has a much more
personality than him there's a certain
kind of whimsicalness about him there's
a charm there's more of a charm and
he's humorous you know he's just like a
quarter of this movie
but he's not in it they call it a hobbit
but the hobbit is like
no i've been not so much i've been
calling it the foreign
peter jackson needs to make a decision
about whether or not this movie is about
bilbo
through bilbo's perspective and going in
and seeing middle earth and
you know maybe the audience you know
kind of sees everything through bilbo's
eyes because bilbo's basically
you know not particularly magical he's
someone the audience can relate to and
he
the whole point of every man exactly and
he gets thrown into all these ridiculous
situations and i found that
he caught his feet yeah his big ass
hairy
big ass hairy reason to see number seven
the production design
with the makeup i thought was really
good i even liked it on the orcs there
was just one new orc they introduced has
like a
slice down his head like that there's
this one moment where gandalf goes to
some i don't know city where he's by
himself he's going solo and i thought
that was really neat
the the whole spider sequence that's the
bread and butter of these movies to me
uh partly is is the production design
and i i
that's the stuff i kind of uniformly
loved about this you know even if
some of the vis effects weren't spot on
i still love the really weird cool
goblin designs you know i thought the
orc looks were just as good as they've
always been i really like the elven
kingdom and the dwarf mines and i
i liked the beehive they lived in yeah
like all these different
you know places you get to see is is
part of the magic of these movies and
that
hasn't shaken for me once over the
course of any of them i do feel though
like if
if they made this movie same screenplay
you know same
script same everything but without such
great special effects
would it still be a good movie i don't
think you could make this movie on a
small budget no
but i needed it to be big it's like one
of those movies that justify is having
it be big
my point is i often i find myself not
liking some aspects of the movie but
then falling back and being like but you
know the effects were great
that's why we have categories well and
that's why no movie is defined by one
thing or the other
i guess i felt like if the production
design wasn't so great then i would have
just absolutely not liked the movie
split decision number one thorin
thorne's a [ __ ] that is a bold
statement i was
trying to get a reaction out of you i'm
sorry it's all good i don't think he
sucks any [ __ ] in this movie
yeah there's not one sequence yeah in
which fellatio is performed on
anyone i think thorin is [ __ ] cool
dude
i like that angry kind of guy who's you
know has
internal complexity and all that [ __ ]
he's he's a leader that
you're like sometimes on board with
sometimes not on board with you're like
conflicted about the opinion you have of
this guy a lot of the time and i kind of
like a character where you feel a little
bit challenged on whether or not you
should like this dude
wait when did you feel like you
shouldn't like him i don't know what
time he doesn't remember anything he did
except like he like stood around
he got mad sometimes you question his
motives what did he do i
forget i'm half with you in the sense
that like i i like
the performance here you know i think he
does a good job with what he's given
the only thing i wish would happen is
that they would give him something else
besides that most of the dwarves i think
i think except for
thorin and gilly like those are the only
two that i mean they i felt like those
two didn't really look like
dwarves you know what i mean i felt like
they look like movie stars thorin
doesn't have like even like the big old
nose and he's gotta be sexy
he's gotta be well i guess so yeah did
you really wanna watch an ugly dwarf the
whole time
split decision number two bard
of the additions to this story like bard
was one of my favorite things in this
yeah
like i really liked him i would have
liked to see a whole movie just about
bard it kind of reminds me of orlando
bloom a little bit
yeah a little bit with with a i was
getting james franco
i like bart's porch in the movie too
because it gave us a different flavor of
production design too like i liked the
look of their city
and the music changed when they got
there and i thought that was a nice
gateway into something
tolkien-esque but new you know split
decision number three
gandalf all 10 minutes of gandalf i like
gandalf i do
i would forget he's in the movie like
yeah he would show up and i'm like oh
yeah i can off i forgot about this guy
it kind of just felt like gandalf being
gandalf again
yeah it's like i like him account and
stuff like that and and while
it's not like his performance of ganaf
has really changed
but i like gandalf much better than lord
of the rings for some reason
there's nothing about him in this film
that's like oh yeah this is a different
side of gandalf i'm glad we're watching
it
well yeah you just kind of have him here
to have it you know is there really room
to really change gandalf's character in
the first place
i'm not asking to change it i'm just
saying make him feel like more of a
character because right now he's sort of
just like a game piece it's like i'm a
wizard
there we go i would like to see gandalf
like with a romantic interest
like like a woman with a beard or
something like that woman
yeah like a dwarf woman that would be
really cool if you gandalf like hooked
up with a dwarf woman
interspeed he showed a picture of the
locket and there's a little joke like
who's this and who's like that's my wife
well
that's dwarf yeah so that woman i'm
thinking
that woman is the locket yeah yeah cause
gandalf wants to get on it
gimli's uh step dad look i i know
that a lot of people are thinking this
about the movie so i'm just going to
address it
if gandalf has that big of a beard
imagine how big his pubic hair must be
this is a visual image that i am a
little bit
that comfortable with but then you would
have to wonder is the beard
just a lack of shaving or a stylistic
choice nature's thing
because he's like you know clean shaven
wizards come on now
yeah i gotta have a righteous beard if
anyone's gonna take me seriously
he's probably well-groomed he probably
just uses that style he'd probably i
mean how would you he would take the
beer
for the chef and he'd whip it around
behind his shoulder
in order to because like if the beard's
in the way he wouldn't be able to even
reach down there
you know what i mean split decision
number four
action the action to me
was absolutely dynamite the i like the
spider sequel there's like four
there's a fine action sequence there's
just one moment i saw in the trailer
with like
the dwarves and barrels going down the
river and there's like orcs and elves
and i thought that was so cool i was
with an audience and i was one of those
people in the audience going
oh so awesome and i love the whole
finale
i'm not really on board with it it just
feels like the need to turn
scenes into roller coaster rides where
they didn't need to be
takes away from the experience of the
story to me because it's a little
it distracted me a little bit oh it
amplified for me i thought this was like
an awesome action fantasy adventure
flick one thing i really liked about
this movie was that even though you know
some of these characters are gonna make
it and they're gonna be fine
i would forget about that like i would
actually be like oh [ __ ] bilbo's in
trouble
then you forget that he's gonna live to
be like 111 years old or something
yeah but no no you're absolutely right
with that you know i was legitimately
scared you know for
bilbo in certain instances i'm like oh
[ __ ] this is the end he gets eaten oh
wait no
no we saw some movies ryan's consensus
i don't care what they say the hobbit
desolation of smog
is the reason movies are made i don't
give a [ __ ] what jerry and rachel say
the hobbit desolation of smog is the
reason movies are made yeah [ __ ] these
guys
jerry's consensus martin freeman is
still the reason to see the hobbit
desolation of smug
martin freeman is still the reason to
see the hobbit desolation of smog
it's like the one thing that is
consistently good to me rachel's
consensus
so basically lack of bilbo and lack of
investment in the characters is a reason
not to see
desolation of smog basically lack of
bilbo
and lack of investment of characters is
a reason not to see the hobbit
desolation of smoke
it seemed like it wasn't particularly
cohesive and it was a lot of little
ideas strung together
by a you know a piece of tape that you
know isn't particularly strong
and you can probably just rip it off
whenever all right guys thanks for
checking out our review for the hobbit
desolation of smog why don't you go
ahead
and scroll that comment box below and
tell us
do you think gandalf has a lot of pubic
hair and once you're done with that
click on this button so you can see more
episodes of reasons to see because we
we've seen other people you know of
course if you want to get updated every
time one of our reviews or videos is out
sub subscribe where were you jerry
we always do it together i'm sorry
you [ __ ] which lord of the rings
character do you think has the biggest
dick
oh gandalf for sure without a doubt i
mean
smallest smallest oh um let's see here
fresh